so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect yo what's up everybody i am
thomas dobaziola whatever you want to
call me this is the dopes usual podcast
i'm here with my
co-host marty o'neal what's up folks
what up guys guys let's get started all
right it's really smoky in here let's
get started guys this episode today
is from
i need to start writing these out like
today's zap is like bruce buffer or
something today's episode is with fki
first first thank you for being here man
thank you for being here
one of the first people that's already
rolled the [ __ ] up and i just cussed and
we're we're in trouble that's all right
that's all right
now i'm just kidding so we can't good
i'm kidding
no we just do this with youtube we just
[ __ ] yeah we sit here and smile out
of the camera thumbs up for the first
five minutes or so usually
we try yeah somebody told me on
instagram if you post cats like a couple
cats you could post anything after that
catch like you know how you can have
like a photo dump uh-huh if you put a
cat as your first picture oh
yo that's kind of that's kind of i have
a homie that does weed [ __ ] and to stay
monetized on youtube every couple videos
he'll just read a kid's book and we'll
smoke
so the algorithm is like no he's fine
damn and then he just jump starts his
[ __ ] back he goes back to us
yeah so real quick just so uh we can
give everybody a little background on
you a lot of people may have all right a
lot of people know your art no you know
your work but might not know the person
behind it and that's usually where
where it happens man it's like
nobody knows the offensive coordinator
that much but he is the person putting
this play together he's shaped careers
every superstar is like that's the way i
see it it's like the mole it's like the
artist that's molding like now try this
try that and i didn't get it until he
explained it to me i didn't realize
producers
are the they are the artist molding i
didn't know that until two years ago
when he showed me he was doing music
i didn't i thought a producer was like a
guy like hill
it sounds great because you know in the
movies yeah you just see the dude
and it extends so far beyond just making
beats
it's the quarterback of the whole
operation it's making sure the job gets
done correctly yeah like when omar sent
me his first song i'm like oh that's
cool he made it and then you took over
it then i thought
wait he's molding the song and then he
was like yeah he told me to make my
voice here and try to do this here it's
more of like
the orchestra guy that's exactly what
this is right mm-hmm see i didn't know
i'm not i mean you got almost everybody
in this room is into music and does
music except for me so i don't really
know
the steps behind it but it's so much
more so i didn't realize so what just
for a few i wrote them down because
there's so many i couldn't really go it
i couldn't really do it all but what is
it white iverson
that damn song that every girl in every
[ __ ] state always sings the a ladies
one jesus christ bro
isn't is it
hit after hit i get it i understand
did you have to eat [ __ ] to get there
did you have to like be
hey man go get some waters and [ __ ] then
come back and you can [ __ ] with the
boards later did you ever have to be
that intern guy i mean yeah i feel like
to make it
in this
whether you're the biggest rapper
biggest producer the biggest ceo
you're gonna have to
be on the other side you like you have
to see both sides like that's the only
way you respect it really
so it's like of course i was coming up i
was working under other producers other
engineers other rappers just trying to
make that [ __ ] sound better we're really
learning from them really you know what
i mean trying to like
see what they do just trying to
help i always felt like if you in the
room
no matter if you feel like you're not if
you feel like you're the least important
the most important person just
bring some help bring something to the
room wherever you go just bring
something like effort
something something like
something like just always always be
doing something whether it's that thing
that you came to do music
just helping the wrong bro but just i
don't know but what was the question
again
how does it feel to to see your uh oh no
that's not what it was i'm already high
i guess yeah that was my next question
my question originally was
people might not know the artist behind
the artist i guess you could say it so i
was trying to say a few there's just too
many men so i was just saying a few of
your credentials to let people know like
oh this is what we're doing today
oh so this is what we're talking about
today because i know people just got
hype just thinking about that yeah
exactly
so i made a lot of stuff for travis
scott
classic i feel like makes travis
the classic travis scott songs uh drugs
you should try
sloppy toppy rp screw
just about every album every project
travis scott post malone
two chains watch out a little [ __ ]
um
it just keeps going yeah man i don't
know i just feel like god put me here to
just i'm like a
i'm like a season two people but a good
season not like people could be like i
had something he's in and out he's gone
but like nah i like i feel like i was
put here to drop in people's lives
sprinkle a little drip and i'm gone
that sounds cool play your role
do your thing
but yeah but i'm on my own path too
though you know what i mean there's it's
a lot it's a lot going on man two people
i look up to especially in atlanta music
probably like two change in the future
because of what they did and the
the route they took
the time it took i look up to both of
them man so like that's that's my next
path man i'm trying to you know going
for the the biggest artist you already
already did the producing [ __ ] and i got
to put
oh yourself yeah yeah i got to produce
myself man i got to put the battery in
my bag cause when i was over there the
other day and you guys were at that
gigantic ass metallica studio the one
you guys were at
that one
i noticed you were yeah you were on the
microphone like since so he made oh i
didn't yeah okay this is for you it was
crazy bro i've always made music but it
was like
i'm not gonna say i was insecure but
i was like always too nice and humble
like say like i'll have the greatest
idea on the song and to be in the studio
with somebody
i know i should keep it and do this like
yeah you would hear this idea yeah yeah
i don't know why i don't can't not tell
him i can't not tell him it's the
craziest [ __ ] but i've been working on
it man you know what i mean i've been
watching i've been watching my kanye
documentaries i was just about to bring
him up as a reference because that's
what he did like he did the blueprint he
did so many behind the scenes things
before he ever before he put out jesus
walks and his album like there was a
whole stretch of his career that people
today probably aren't even aware of and
i mean like where he was behind the
scenes adding value to all these other
superstars and gaining his own work yeah
you want to know some crazy some crazy
[ __ ] about this why people know like
they've heard my production but don't
really know who i am
i have this like flashback all the time
look like eight to nine years ago
at sunny digital's apartment with metro
booming a couple other producers there
sonny digital was like hey bro you need
a tag for your beats bro your beast is
too hard bro why don't you have a tag
i'm like i can't find one sonny
i can't find one i don't know what where
the [ __ ] y'all getting these tags from
but that day uh it hits me every time
every time so i i've never forgot his
words like i could
see put myself like in that room and see
everybody because like a lot of the
atlanta producers came up like we came
up together like speaking of sunny metro
uh
tm 88
even weezy bro weezy had one of the
greatest come-ups i've seen he would
just always just be in the room he
wouldn't be bothering anybody just even
back to like t.i days like when he was
just young like shout out wheezy man
wheezy out of here where the camera's at
yeah
but all the atlanta producers bro it's
just like a community and like we
everybody came up beautiful thing bro
but yeah i just didn't have a [ __ ]
tag
how'd you get it
huh how'd you get it who made it
now i have a tag jer larry i said jerry
june
larry june did my my first tag that
people noticed
he was saying like good job first even
though people thought it was saying
[ __ ] i'm first but it was a good job
first it was larry june and um
after he did that i kind of just ran
with it now my name is good job first on
a lot of stuff so shout out to larry
june but now it's um my new tag is first
thing geeked it up y'all are going to be
hearing it on some songs coming up
yeah i got some new stuff with draco the
ruler coming out um rp uh ralphie
pz jack harlow
beautiful
nice man well well the first time i ever
came we'll say won't say what year was a
long time ago i walked in with some weed
i looked at i was telling him the other
day i walked in and just saw
so many platinum albums like yo where
the [ __ ] am i because i'm from nobody
make nobody does [ __ ] where i'm from and
especially not just being a wee person
you don't see things like that so when i
walk in i'm like
it's different for me i mean you guys
get it you guys do music i understand
that you're like oh yeah you know he
produced this and produced that
once you start seeing credentials and
start going wait how do you have the
time to do all this [ __ ] like this is
what i do when i it's like me busting
out videos like
it's my baby this is what i've been
doing yeah so when i see
the sheer
number of
over and over pl i just see all of it
how does that go from when you started
because i i have a question um
because you're from atlanta i get i
understand who what is it your family
who and your fam because it always comes
down to that every artist i ask where
did you get the spark was there an older
uncle or an aunt that just loved music
and you just got stuck my on my the
african side of my family from liberia
my uncle was actually uh
he was actually an artist in africa he's
he was up to like really especially west
africa like lit as [ __ ] but um i always
saw his records at the house and my pops
bro
for african dude my pops had every vinyl
still like to this day my basement right
now from led zeppelin to bob marley and
the whalers like everybody bruh every
that's what i first saw i remember being
in my basement
i picked up a queen album i didn't even
know who the [ __ ] it was i just picked
up the queen album i just saw it because
the four dudes on it let me look at this
real quick i put it in bruh duh i never
forgot this day i put it in that [ __ ]
dude
and i was a little kid i never heard
that [ __ ] before you know i mean you'll
hear it later as you grow up on tv and
[ __ ] but i heard it myself like i press
play myself i was like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ]
oh my god that was just one random song
that happened to me a lot of times like
so like when i make music i just try to
give people that feeling like because
you all remember like the first time you
heard a fight song like where's your
favorite song of course i saw i just try
to make do that every time yeah
something to resonate yeah yeah you
gotta feel that [ __ ] every time you
start love it man so you saw your uncle
so you see him like you got albums what
the [ __ ] he's popping yeah
yeah yeah he he actually died though he
died in liberia um yeah it's crazy you
look it up i'm about to put his uh all
his music out on like itunes and [ __ ]
but go watch that vice documentary in
liberia too yeah oh yeah liberia is
crazy bro
liberia is one of the craziest places on
earth and safe to say but it's a
beautiful place too though that's the
crazy you ever been because now i
haven't cause we've
it's like
when like to go back it's just like a
lot of [ __ ] going on kind of like on and
off on and off so i just i just haven't
been but i plan on going like real real
so nice tight yeah yeah especially have
roots in another place like that that
you can actually go
back and see is so tight yeah i think i
got like a diamond mine there or
something no
i gotta find that hole you inherited
everything you gotta find that [ __ ] bro
[ __ ]
all right so quick question i have
somebody uh i wanted to ask who does
this person mean to you because i got it
marty uh can i can i do it okay because
this relates to me i came up in music
heavy duty lynn got a buffalo one of my
producers my main producers that i
worked with was like
my best friends he um was my god he's my
daughter's godfather technically
which is crazy because you know he lives
in atlanta now actually but
when we were coming up like and it was
like a lot of my boys were like he would
he'd end up like sleeping at the uh
library end up being on the streets his
parents were super religious once we
started going hard with the music they
like disowned and basically end up
staying in my mom's basement i'm not
even living there we're just recording
i'm coming back to my mom's house he's
living in the basement we're recording
and then i'm leaving how he lived there
yeah i was living with my wife now in
her apartment
i'm coming to my mom's house
and he's yeah like it was like that for
months and then he ended up going down
to atlanta but
we saw this video uh of at charlie
talking about your story and that when
when he was describing like what you
went through like your transition it
should just like really resonated with
me because like i we went through that
same [ __ ] yeah man yo shout out charlie
first and foremost man his the way he's
grown because like
he's one of the greatest managers in
music even though he retired from music
like so the crazy thing is i'll meet
random people that want to be managers
and [ __ ] that want to do certain [ __ ]
but i'm like damn you're not even close
as my boy charlie brother like check
this out i'm saying some crazy [ __ ]
random story about charlie to some side
[ __ ]
his first
the song a ladies that we did those
dudes travis porter we did like three
other songs to make it rain and the song
called bring it back but when we made
those songs bro
he drove he started in georgia
drove all the way up north like along
the coast to every radio station even
though bootleg like the little bootleg
radio stations in the smallest city and
handed them the music bro
he was gone for like a month bro yeah
dro what year is this this is probably
like 2 000 like 11 maybe 10 i don't even
know
the internet era people aren't yeah
but still yeah
they were still taking over the internet
too yeah but he literally drove and
shook every radio person's hand i'm like
what the [ __ ] bro that's some [ __ ] bro
yeah people want dedication that's
dedicated
that's dedication for your artist bro
yeah people would never do no [ __ ] like
that bro like literally somebody will
laugh if you yeah they didn't even ask
him he just did it himself though that's
somebody treating it like it's their own
like bro and then after that he did two
chains
bankrolled fresh damn there he damn that
helped a little bit with
uh
uh young dolph 2 early early but yeah
bro charlie a real one bro and is he
he's a motivational speaker now or
whatever yeah yeah
he's got a million followers yeah he's
been the most i've seen him everywhere
and then he showed me like this [ __ ]
dude i've seen on tick tock all the time
help [ __ ] out
bray used to be yeah race being in the
trap in the hood helping all the artists
bro in the trap room like no cap like
all in his mom basement all the rappers
used to come to his basement to do like
this podcast called like spit your game
like this is earth long time ago
soldier boy too he helped soldier boy he
was his breath the soldier boy does
atlanta is he from atlanta as far as
music's concerned like does atlanta
claim soldier boy i mean a little bit
yeah i mean he he's like from like
mississippi that's what i'm saying but
in my mind he always came out of atlanta
but i knew he wasn't actually from
atlanta yeah i always like usher too
right same [ __ ]
i heard about soulja boy game based yeah
he just told me
you're telling me
no it wasn't me somebody else was just
in this room yeah
he got amazed by who
yeah uh oh you just told me by some guy
they talk [ __ ] charleston dude who is
that who we drama is it the older dude
he like a he like a ratchet version of
charlie he do like hood motivation
speeches
yo dude is crazy he's not crazy though
he be saying real [ __ ] it's just
everybody can't handle it it'd just be
like too real for his own oh
no no he just says it like he wants you
to punch him in the face is he the
southern dude yeah yeah i've seen him
then he was talking [ __ ] the other day
about somebody and they would know that
it was like uh
would you take a hundred thousand to uh
to sit down with jay-z
or something else he's like
i'll take a hundred thousand [ __ ] jay-z
i'm sorry i'm jay-z you're great but i'm
gonna take that hundred pans oh yeah i
didn't say that
yeah
though but jay-z goat though here
he laid them down that's marty that's
all marty he swear i'm already trying to
get me
into jay-z
but no i played in my lifetime buying
one foreign
imaginary player bro
imaginary player
imaginary player set my life like
don't be that guy he talking about
what's the difference between the 4.0
4.6 30 to 40 grand [ __ ] sucker
he tried i still i only i'm only two
albums in bro i grew up on west coast
[ __ ] my mom's mad i know she's watching
my mom was mad ignorant she told me
biggie smalls can't rap and tupac's the
best rapper alive when i was a kid i'm
like
really big really so i never listened to
dallas 19 years old and then i realized
like mom you're a liar yeah yeah but you
don't even know but speaking of up north
new york music though i'm i'm from
atlanta i live in atlanta i wasn't
really [ __ ] with it at first when i
first heard jay-z and all that [ __ ]
coming from like what the [ __ ] is this
i'm listening to three six mafia
all this [ __ ] from atlanta
yeah pastor choi this [ __ ] i was in the
heart about this for this morning so
look i didn't really so i didn't really
understand it but one day it like
clicked when i was like 17 or something
18 like
wanted his song he made a song called
like breathe easy or something yeah
oh [ __ ] my bad yeah like
i looked up at this guy
i looked up at the sky like hey if this
[ __ ] can hear me or god
send this message my bad for hate and
like i'm i was stupid i was deep into
his career yeah just circled back to
like three yeah but then after that i
went all the way back bro but it's like
he really gives you the blueprint to
become rich and to be successful if you
paid [ __ ] it as a self-made independent
yeah yeah and i'm from the south i
wasn't even like but yeah he do he like
that blueprint down [ __ ] crazy
man i remember when um
memphis bleak did that remix with t.i
wow
that whole era like i put my daughter on
to different areas of music every time
we go to school and [ __ ] today we had
pastor troy and urban legend on the show
because
atlanta had that whole era of like real
legit music that classic era but then
like soulja boy d4l came about and we
were talking about this earlier it kind
of made it cool to not be a rap and ass
rapper anymore at that point or i i
could just say it was more about
diverted hip-hop you got to just get
your cool offline yeah you guys became
youtube hip-hop from that point but
so like atlantic in my mind took a lot
of slack for like
like
non-lyrical rap becoming famous but
southern playlists and cadillac music
equipment i like all those albums like
killer mic all that [ __ ] is just classic
hip-hop right next to ill-matic and all
that other [ __ ] mm-hmm yeah yes but
i just feel like
i feel like in atlanta it changed like
all right
it was like
what you were saying the classic classic
classic but then it started it had to
get fun knowing everybody started
turning up because i feel like atlanta
was always fun atlanta always had like
ass shaking music like
from the strip clubs twerk music well
john came out yeah
that's one of my heroes
that [ __ ] too hard nothing like it
before though right too hard now they
literally starting fights in the club
like oh [ __ ] oh look oh wait bro when i
was in high school when i used to dj
bruh
like
if me and my friends want to go home
we look at each other like y'all ready
to go bro
y'all ready to go we might have some
hoses on me i'm ready to go all right
cool cool i'm about to play headbuster
real quick and then it's just like you
know you just started to be like
the whole club
and we're in high school
or not
it was some dude called abg anybody get
it and they just used to go to work they
just they either they song come on so
other songs come on if you that unlucky
dude
you and your friend it's a wrap it's
your ass i remember one time we had a
party you know
you like a skating rink or ice break ice
rink or something like that
bruh
it was abg time it was my fault i played
head busters um but they closed like the
doors on the rink and just chased these
the couple dudes
just gotta get out the way when abg go
through but it was like that in the
letter just a certain place walking in
them used to do that too bro when
walking in first came out get the [ __ ]
out the way oh yeah i could see that get
the [ __ ] out the way hit squad in there
and bring squad like some monsters
it is it it really is like some mosh pit
[ __ ] really like atlanta and in atlanta
like memphis and [ __ ] it like it's slick
it's my spit [ __ ]
really just hip hop really
my speech bowl is everything yeah just
hip-hop but um
why can't they know but they used to be
whoopi ass but i want to get him on here
i feel like his story is great right now
right i remember this once i thought it
was going to beat me up bro that's crazy
bro let me tell you bro 667 right it's
the first time it's the first time where
i like got some real money and music and
i figured out like oh
the money ain't always it like
you gotta have morals and everything
like for real this is the first like
so look i go to the studio walking gucci
and it's like after i just made making
rain i go to the studio walking gucci we
make the hardest song ever bro like
i sample cry me a river timberland and
walk it
gucci on it the hardest [ __ ] ever but
look the next day i'm at another studio
playing it or like mixing it
random as [ __ ] ludacris walks in the
room and it's like i want that song
i want waka on there too
i'm like wait what
and like like
gucci snapped it so it was like
but he was like
and i'll give you 25 000. i was like
that's my first time ever hearing like
like for the other beats i probably got
like a thousand dollars bro like this
man said twenty five thousand dollars
for one beat and he gone he was gonna
have it for me in two days like i didn't
even believe i'm like but then he really
did for me in two days i'm like oh [ __ ]
had you worked with him before that or
no no no no no that was the first time
so bam he takes the song walk is still
on it
so look he calls uh i guess of course
wacko finds out somewhere like you're on
the song ludicrous now because he
literally bought the whole song
bro walker called me i think my friend
quest caught me for travel support he
was like hey bro why can't mad at you
bro hey bro that [ __ ] matters [ __ ] what
you do bro i'm like
man
i'm like damn so i'm like oh my god this
is about to be crazy like [ __ ]
like mad man they took gucci off the
song and like he's featuring on the song
and it just meant like
it just all happened so fast yeah
so yeah fast forward though video shoot
time i was gonna see him at the video
shoot bruh
i go live slick scared like we do but we
get to the video shoot but look
everything ends up being okay because
they paid walker like a hundred thousand
to do the video in the song bruh so he
was like yeah whatever thanks
got me paid today but look though that
we missed out on the classic song though
like for real this is this gucci
song though with some classic trap [ __ ]
bruh
and
i [ __ ] it up over 25 grand i get what
you're saying now like sometimes it's
not worth it you probably needed that
then more than you need like and i mean
that was like i can imagine that moment
25 times your rate
oh you know my brain yeah i was like
sleep still broke that [ __ ] was
like what you about to give me what
yeah just
i can see i get what you're saying
but damn he's like those buddies
do those artists still get those budgets
like that these days like they could
just throw around like
i know it's not like i mean he was rich
already ludicrous was already rich at
that time he got them joaquin coming out
like he was already filthy right [ __ ] to
him yeah making a good ass song yeah
yeah he was already up so wait you could
be an artist
so walk right he gets his song sold by
you
and now he's obligated to go make the
video they pay i mean they paid him for
it i mean if without it
could he say i don't want to be on the
song with ludacris
take me off is he allowed to say that as
an artist yeah they could but i'm sure
the same way i was like
right when they say the honeymoon all
right
okay so no i never knew that like damn
you just got a call you're on a song
with ludacris now like since when
so how does it work now at this level
like do people come at you do you come
at artists you want to work with is it
like case by case
bro i'm like a hippie with this [ __ ] bro
i'm like
i'm like one of my another one of my
heroes george clinton i look up to him
he make like group music like
if you creative and you fire [ __ ] just
be in a room at that time and that [ __ ]
let's make some magic that's how like i
am like day to day
but um
i just try to just stay around like cool
cool creative people it's like two types
of people i work with
it's either it's
two
two things either
it's the most far
out craziest
sonics and music you ever heard crazy
weird [ __ ] over there
or it's
the hardest most authentic street [ __ ]
it's just those two things and over here
in this genre it could be anything any
genre like i can i like making anything
like
collabing and like connecting and
everything so those are the two things i
like working with
that makes any sense yeah yeah hell yeah
oh yeah so real quick to circle back as
we're all high as hell
when we were talking about your homie
charlie so he's the one that helped you
start up your career essentially um
there's
he's one of the three there's three
people who helped me charlie definitely
but it was more like we at that time we
didn't even notice we were helping like
each other and [ __ ] like
because at that time i was i was mixing
songs for like fifty dollars and like
damn they're free most of the [ __ ] i was
doing was free in atlanta yeah in
atlanta how'd you come across this
person um it was his uh dude named hank
mr hanky
shout out to mr hanky or producer named
mrs hankey i just saw him like not too
long ago but yeah he uh
he's the one who really really put me in
the position i don't know where i met
him maybe a club or something
but
my friend was like yeah he make beats
and engineer all that [ __ ] y'all link up
so i don't know when to link with him
and a link went to link with this dude
named mr kylo park i don't know if y'all
know who that is you know he was a
legendary producer from atlanta but um
mr kyler park i just i was around them
just watching [ __ ]
they let me touch the computer and [ __ ]
other people didn't like that was my
first time you know what i mean like
touch like other than my [ __ ] like i'm
touching somebody else's computer
working making some [ __ ] touches i'm
like oh [ __ ] these dudes they cool bro
they let me do this [ __ ] so they let me
experiment and then they were like then
he made me with travis porter and travis
supporters manager was charlie
and um at that time they were working a
mixtape they were making a mixtape with
waka called streets rs
and
i started mixing their songs i just
started doing [ __ ] from there and they
would just link me with other people i'm
telling i was doing it for them they're
free like dollars a hundred dollars
and the first person that ever paid me
there was just doing a rocco shout out
to rocco here rapper i mixed this song
he gave me 500 i was like damn [ __ ]
i was like oh [ __ ]
for real this could happen so then
that's like when it started it clicked
like oh [ __ ] i ain't asked for this
somebody's just like yo you got to have
this [ __ ] you just snapped so
it gave me a little confidence you know
a little better of course then from
there just moved on and uh
yeah i just always knew i i wanted to be
a producer and do this [ __ ] make this
[ __ ] i just had to figure out how
like i always tell you you don't know
how just find a way into a studio
you'll figure out the rest from there
like whether you're touching [ __ ] or not
just find a way into a studio so that
was the first day you
weren't
on your own i mean you weren't just
by yourself yeah yeah yeah you show you
whatever
like a basement dude like you know what
i mean or no bedroom because like it's
just different once something once you
just [ __ ] with someone else's [ __ ]
so when did you start
start making music in general like
because i know you said earlier you see
your uncle's scene doing all this [ __ ]
your dad has all these [ __ ] vinyls
which
what busts out some queen is what i'm
hearing right
i get that because first time i heard
queen i was like
what do you mean he just killed a man
he's going to go home for it but what is
called
like broke my [ __ ] heart as a guy i
remember where i was right before james
and giant peach came out about six years
old and i remember listening that song
like you just killed somebody why are
you telling your mom what song is this
[ __ ] me up you remember i remember
that [ __ ] yeah it was it was here in
thousand oaks when i lived when i lived
down here
and um
so what's the what's the first time you
actually
touch the music you know what i mean
you're listening to [ __ ]
first time you get something and start
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
i started
messing around with fruity loops like
early i don't know what number that was
we don't really lose 20 now i think it
was like
four or five or for the group four or
five i don't even know
but this kid showed me in seventh eighth
grade i started messing around with it
whatever
but then in ninth grade
ninth grade that's when i figured out
man this you know i knew in sixth grade
i hated school but in ninth grade i'm
like oh yeah this [ __ ] sucks i failed
every single class bro oh literally like
and i have a twin sister too that makes
the perfect grade so it was like yin
so i mean obviously not identical but do
you guys look you know what i'm saying
because i know one that's a girl and a
boy and they look appropriate
she look like my pops i look like my mom
all right i was like damn this was
[ __ ] up over here she's killing it
yeah yeah so um oh yeah some someone
african well african parents don't play
that [ __ ] oh i feel like all foreign
parents don't [ __ ] around with that [ __ ]
depending i guess where you're from but
they was like you ain't going nowhere
i'm like what you mean like literally
nowhere i couldn't go nowhere that year
not in ninth grade and that summer and
[ __ ]
but
i learned how to make beats though
fruity loops because i couldn't go
nowhere but i could get on the computer
so it's like i literally learned that
year and then the next year they started
playing all my beats and [ __ ] the
basketball games football games and they
come out and [ __ ] oh yeah yeah so it was
like there was this stuff that started
rushing right there dude especially when
you see your own classmates like
so it started right there i'm like and
i'm seeing people's reactions like when
they come out like oh [ __ ] never turn
i'm like oh yeah this is it oh yeah this
is him right here so damn you were young
already knew what you were doing so then
i just had to sit through school i was
[ __ ] up a couple years
bro i knew what i wanted to do and i'm
like bro what the [ __ ] and like i sli i
had to go cause i have a twin sister
because she going every day and she want
to go every day so
so it's like i can't even skip really
because it's like one person is there
you know what i'm saying
right look my other friends could skip
and [ __ ] because they was like the only
child or the only person that great
[ __ ]
like it was crazy it was [ __ ]
the same grades probably in the state
classes and she's trying to show her
grades she makes straight age bruh [ __ ]
i'm so glad my sister was worse than me
dude i just be listening to the clock
like bro i used to hold my breath when i
was a kid to see how long i hold my
breath to pass time in class
did you not do that nobody else did oh
my bad [ __ ] did i try i don't know
minute and a half sixth grade
a minute and a half bro i was 40 minutes
go by fast
because you have to catch your breath
for 30 seconds
i'm telling i hated school so [ __ ] i was
in all the accelerated malcolm in the
middle program or
the smart kid [ __ ] so they gave me
more stuff
that was my sister was doing too yeah i
was your sister except i was you right
and your sister's [ __ ]
i hated it bro you smoking bleeding high
school
like
i was i didn't really have money but
like i mean like to smoke like so i was
just smoking it was there so i was
smoking [ __ ] [ __ ] but then i
can't forget this day oh
what was this kid named i don't know
this white kid with braces in my
neighborhood he was like
oh come on i was gonna be playing video
games and [ __ ] so i go his older brother
brought some gas dog
dog i had never smoked gas in my life
like it was gas
it was so beautiful i never forgot that
day like that almost the same as when i
heard my favorite songs bro i smoked i
was like what the [ __ ] is happening to
me but on some crazy [ __ ] his brother
also had ice and like snorted that [ __ ]
i didn't [ __ ] with that was like so the
first time i found gas i saw that too i
was like
i did not think this was gonna go
he pressed some icing she ordered that
[ __ ] i was like
i'm not doing that i'm gonna [ __ ] with
this right here i'm [ __ ] some weed
good look at the path that could have
been a different [ __ ] path real quick
that was the fourth in the road you
gotta think of that man oh [ __ ]
oh
that was the right
for you see he thought in his instance
when he hit that fork in the road he hit
the ball and then they said oh there's
meth that's what happened to me i smoked
some weed and then they're like
oh there's there's meth on him no
[ __ ] that was my path yeah i got tricks
[ __ ] about that
i've heard so many stories like i've
heard stories like that everywhere but a
lot in california that is like
california like smoking a lace blend
i'll be hearing that all the time that
like bulls are tripping why would you
want to wait i think it's a waste of
weed
the stronger drug is going to win in
this situation
what they call it getting wet
yeah i didn't know
i got my weave yeah i got my weed dipped
and i took it and that's the time i
[ __ ] i thought i was having a [ __ ]
stroke in my dad's bathroom i smoked
some some laced weed dude i couldn't
make it up the stairs and i my vision
started getting like fish high and i'm
just starting to [ __ ] hyperventilate
the bathroom and i just laid there for
like an hour that happened to me one
time in life too that's all yeah one
instance i went to the deepest darkest
depths of the east side got the
shittiest bag of just dust weed
oh in new york i was coming out of my
body now it was bad for a long time yeah
and this is this is coming out of your
body yeah
it was horrible
oh you had a lace blunt too yeah
it wasn't regular weed
i always remembered it forevermore i was
like i feel like i'm dying right now
i felt like i was leaving my body like i
was trying to i kept having i feel like
i remember like holding the counter like
oh yeah my head dumped the [ __ ] toilet i
hated it my head started was like mr
mackey in south park i think i'm a
fighter
i'm like
don't hit it
you [ __ ] mushrooms and all that type
of stuff yeah we [ __ ] mushrooms and
[ __ ] yeah omar told us about you guys
trip
oh yeah in the desert yeah yeah we made
the classic song that last night
we made a classic song bruh nice so it
was worth it that's sick that you guys
do that like we were talking about it
last time like uh what do we call it
like uh uh
it's like
i think it's kind of [ __ ] up
i'm nike i'm gonna go get the top six
kids to school with the best grades in
this technology thing hey we're going to
pay you 200
just give just start thinking of stuff
we're going to give you airbnb drink do
whatever you want and they own
everything you came up with and that's
how they come up with new technology
it's called the think tank okay and
[ __ ] just giving away their ips
like chilling and showering yo it's
[ __ ] up this is the company's like we
spent a thousand dollars made a billion
i [ __ ] love it yeah so that's what i
feel like think tank where everybody
just gets but this one's a good one but
in the music world it's like this is
getting away from your kids and you're
only focused on music that's like the
best that's like
game time for a uh athlete
when you're just you have no no
especially when you're like out in the
desert or something no
oh for sure there's
no neighbors no one's gonna come bug you
mm-hmm that shit's tight so before we
started he was like we're gonna have a
smoke off and and molly yeah he
challenged you before this time
was a joke i know you're kidding i know
you're kidding but speaking of drugs do
you dabble in psychedelics
[Music]
just always micro doses
when it comes to those kind of things i
like the microdoses i don't like when my
reality change changed too much like i
got you you know what i mean because you
can't do nothing all right yeah
one time i took one time i took acid
this [ __ ] at the studio turned into a
witch oh [ __ ] and then my other homie he
was like
this is the ground he was like this big
it was so scary bro like it wasn't scary
but it was scary and like
i just had to put my blanket over my
head
alright i do that i have to put my
blanket over and just chill like it just
be just
ride it out close your eyes so then i
wake up i mean i wasn't it's not that i
would sleep i finally take the blanket
off my head i look outside hours have
passed my homie homie my conan is just
sitting on a fence
on a fence just looking into the sky
for like
four hours
like
it what was crazy i was i saw him on the
camera i probably watched for like 15
minutes you're watching him just
watching the sky and [ __ ]
yeah it's crazy psychedelics the trolls
on one still do outside on the fence
sitting on a like a wooden fence i'm
just trying to make it like a wooden
fence like like a cat my one good
mushroom trip i did that i just looked
straight up in the sky like i don't even
know how long i was out there
just 90 degree angle just staring
straight up coming out of my body is the
most fun i've ever had in my life
you took that one [ __ ] what's that [ __ ]
called what
i was about to call it db i see it's not
called dbs
no i haven't done it
yeah no no um i just take big amounts of
mushrooms
and at that level like i start i go in
the dark no music
that's just scary but it's tight as f
like i've never experienced something
like that mm-hmm like i'll i will never
forget it so if you ever have some time
eight hours of not doing [ __ ] go in the
dark and trip out
i haven't done acid though wait in the
dark
yeah i turn all the lights in my room
off no music you probably saw he's right
you see what's in your head it like
projects out like when you close your
eyes and you start dreaming
you start seeing what's in your head
because your brain has nothing to
process it's the [ __ ] weirdest
little trick
i don't know man it was the most fun
i've ever had in my life i'll say that
and also the scariest time of my life yo
next time you do that though
turn on
like on some speakers go to youtube and
type in hemisync
h-e-m-i that's why
just why you do that next time just
typing in dude i'm gonna get possessed
is that like frequencies yeah it's
frequencies and they split your brain
apart like it it [ __ ] with both sides
so you know how to use
what the [ __ ]
see he goes deep into audio that's cool
yeah cause i've heard about frequencies
while tripping and it can do some [ __ ]
yeah
hey what's up guys just taking a moment
to talk about one of our longtime
sponsors and this is manscape summer's
almost over don't be a dirty dick
[ __ ] if you're a fan of the show
you already know manscaped has been here
since almost the beginning shout out to
manscape first off if you have a dirty
ass dick you need to shave your balls
go to manscape.com forward slash yola
from that you'll get 20 off of anything
to make your dick not gross plus free
shipping so guys 100 go get the weed
whacker the brand new lawnmower the 4.0
guys skin safe waterproof has wireless
charging everything there's no excuses
all right use it weed whacker knows hair
trimmer they have everything you can
possibly think of even deodorant for
your balls manscape's got everything you
can possibly think of and if you're a
girl watching this and if you don't have
anybody in life to get this for
we sell travel bags if you don't have
balls you can still go to manscape.com
forward slash yola get 20 off plus free
shipping so from the ultra smooth
package the performance package to the
weed whacker manscaped has something for
everyone also performance package 4.0 or
the platinum package 4.0 get any of
those and get the travel bag and
underwear 60 value guys included for
free so guys thank you so much for
supporting the brands that support us
back to the episode
top five favorite rappers of all time
top five favorite rappers of all time
all right
jay-z gucci man
too short
um
wait jay-z gucci mane too short
usually only have a top three all right
i like this yeah it gives you a little
more range jay-z gucci mane
i always say gucci mane is like
the same thing as jay-z just from
atlanta and he don't uh
he don't articulate the same way that's
funny i was gonna say articulate and
then you said this [ __ ]
but um
[ __ ]
all right sorry
but uh
[ __ ]
i'll tell you what it is folk though the
way everybody uh doing them in them
what's what's up you know how like on
the internet they'd be like they don't i
don't like that eminem disrespect i
haven't seen any of this [ __ ] oh yeah
well maybe i just get on my phone post i
get the [ __ ] off sometimes i haven't
seen any of it but
i maybe it's on the on the black gram or
the black to it or something like that
it'd be disrespectful even though i'm
like saying he's not good at rappers or
not they do they should be they just be
going in like
we don't be knowing he'll be talking
about or you're right so i just be i
just heard it i'm like i don't like that
y'all better start disrespecting him and
uh
just off the strength of who he was or
are you still in tune with his current
music yeah i mean yeah his i feel like
his newest [ __ ] ain't the greatest he
still be like snapping like you know i
mean he's like lyricists and [ __ ] but
like
those those early albums and early
freestyles that just used to randomly
come out i'm like yeah
look when i say a top five i feel like i
have to qualify it by years like give me
like i'm including slim shady for his
first three albums i'm including little
wayne's carter era got you
but it was what's crazy when i include
lil wayne i don't even include the
carter even that all happened i [ __ ]
with
earth like the block is hot
and 500 and 500 degrees all that [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah even like yeah all right
waiting to go too damn i got
all right all right top five
jay-z gucci mane too short kanye
um
ah
and um
[Music]
[ __ ]
future is one of my favorite artists
though but
it might be in yeah
that's the hardest question future bro
and that's rap that's the red top yeah
right
yeah
yeah it's like how you put effort into
that [ __ ] though that's a big question
that is huge but that [ __ ] is real bro
people don't understand you can one you
can learn a lot about somebody from the
question you just asked like you can lit
i have like five different random tests
you can learn a lot from like who are
your
favorite superheroes top three oh bro
it's my favorite [ __ ] what's your
favorite weed is my my number one uh
i'll give it away [ __ ] it when i talk to
growers or people that want to do
business with me in the weed industry i
ask what's your favorite [ __ ] weed to
smoke and if they don't say og kush i
don't [ __ ] do anything with them
because most growers smoke so many
[ __ ] strains and og's gonna be the
strongest highest punch
of most weeds and if they don't say i
like to get shit-faced high after the
long day you're not a real [ __ ]
grower that's all i know it well back to
that to i guess you're right cause i was
gonna say the only time i do smoke og is
when i'm completely done with everything
thank you every every everything i know
i'm not doing [ __ ]
and i'm about to go to sleep or just
chill for a couple days or something
you're right yeah like a girl but i
don't smoke kush every day a hard day's
work is a real grower homeowners are
really working so at the end of the day
i guarantee they want to smoke and go to
sleep so that's my little
test question so you say superheroes
my favorite superhero is batman the
[ __ ] got no powers
yeah
i hate that thought i love that
yeah he's like a baller though he's like
they're just original i think it was
michael keaton and i was born in 89.
it's really well see like because you
could judge a lot off somebody like if
somebody be like nightcrawler you'd be
like what the [ __ ] oh you're a freaky
ass [ __ ]
someone said like
you could you could like you could learn
a lot from somebody about who their
favorite superhero nightcrawler exactly
that's what i'm saying like night girl
you'd be like okay you're a freaky boy
you know that's such a good way to put
it back because you're not wrong like
wolverine all right you a man
you want to punch somebody in the chest
yeah like i expect like a bad i feel i
expect my bad [ __ ] to be like storm
like don't they say that i'd be like
yeah she's cool she holly berry played
her in the morning
because
is that where you said that [ __ ] okay i
get that but
i [ __ ] with that that's a good that's a
good question all right real quick i
don't even have this written down
you and omar chill a lot so i have a
feeling you guys
have a lot in common what are your top
favorite movies you don't have to give
me a top list what are your favorite
movies and that's how i can tell who a
person somebody told me
their favorite movie what was it
i think it was your ass and i got pissed
thomas's cable guy though like he really
oh yeah cable guy that's me man
i'm not weird and [ __ ]
same [ __ ] like i grew up my mom was like
i'mma smoke this [ __ ] chris watch
this [ __ ] i'm like hell yeah so like i
was raised on saturday and [ __ ] and like
shows you know so what are your favorite
movies like top three all right you can
watch forever
top three movies i can watch my movie
genres are crazy though too cause i love
horrible movies i have a just
horrible horror like horrible oh that's
fine like i have a genre where it's like
i love bad movies too though like what
like what let me tell my good first my
favorite movie right a bronx tale good
[ __ ] yes yeah bro all right bronx tale
good fellas [ __ ]
and um
i want to say casino but you like robert
de niro by chance
and he and all three of them
guess i do
but um
[ __ ]
all right those three there's more
though of course friday
the friday franchise yeah
it's i can watch it for it i can watch
it right now you really can the best
about all the friday movies is when you
haven't seen them in a long time like so
and then you've been chasing one
cracking the [ __ ] up bro that [ __ ] is
amazing like that's inspirational fine
little things too it's like what the
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] do y'all do that like
yo one thing i saw recently on thank god
for the internet
i watched friday a [ __ ] 300 i
couldn't tell you how many times did you
notice iselle in the very beginning when
they're panning he's running in the
background with box with the box that he
probably got five craig probably got
fired for and this motherfucker's like
stole some boxes
oh whoa
he [ __ ] me up
i saw it on the internet it could i
could be wrong and i'm like yo that
looks like he's running with boxes is
that at the beginning of the very
beginning during the credits when
they're still panning over there that's
the crazy
[ __ ] they hard
too hard dj poo shout out to dj you're a
hard [ __ ] bro i've been trying
to i think i hit him up before he
probably like who the [ __ ] is this kid
he's cool [ __ ] i know i've been trying
i've been trying to hit him up my ice
cube because i want to make my next
thing i'm going into good gas films
that's what i want to get into later but
i'm like i got to talk to them first i
just want to see you he's the man i mean
they the og's on that [ __ ] truly
yeah dude you can see that [ __ ] that
blew my mind 20 years later i've been
looping this movie never noticed or when
she's calling him talking about who the
[ __ ] were you with last night
there's a [ __ ] dude in her bed
oh yeah i didn't notice that for like
the first three years as a kid damn you
weren't back looking for details no i
just noticed these things over time
those are jeans that's a there's a
[ __ ] dude in her bed right there no i
didn't notice i didn't notice so fridays
pretty much all robert deniros
so then i mean so i got my hood movie
category and like bootleg i love bootleg
movies b movies all them [ __ ]
so like amazon got them all too amazon
got all the boulet movies uh youtube too
like what like what uh y'all seen buffed
up
buffed up nah
buffed up it's about it's in detroit
right you know buffs the cartier glasses
right okay the whole movie is about some
dudes trying to get some cardiac glasses
to [ __ ] [ __ ]
because if you got buffs in detroit you
that [ __ ] so that's what the whole
movie is about and i saw it a couple of
years ago i ended up finding a artist
from watching this movie like this
artist named cash dog i was watching the
movie she was in it i'm like her voice
is hard wait the one you worked with
right mm-hmm
ended up hitting her up bro we we got it
no maybe i don't know if it's gold or
platinum we got like two songs that went
crazy bro just with southern hood movies
and ratchet movies though it was a good
movie buffed up
what else what else what else um
buffed up
[ __ ] there's more there's more
you're talking about like c movies like
c plus movies i get you what else you're
watching but buffed up it's like the top
one right now though that's like the top
hood movie right now nobody's topped
that yet
um you see conflicted
which one zelda put out whatever you
have
it was cool of course it was amazing the
only thing i kept
i'm not gonna ruin it but the ending is
one of the hardest endings i the movie's
okay but that ending
pretty simple
pretty simple
most crazy unrealistic and most
realistic thing i've ever seen it's just
west side gun killing a person but like
cinematically through the perry project
oh my god that was hard as [ __ ] and then
he buys a name
yeah yo you just gotta watch even if you
just watch the end of the movie just
watch the last four [ __ ] seconds this
is rare right now beers
yeah man appreciate you
guys got one morning oh you have that
one with a spike in it yeah my hands
about next
all right cool cool so you got some good
movies man no does your top five artists
does that kind of extend into like who
you'd like to work with in a perfect
best case scenario that wasn't top five
bars i was top five rappers rappers okay
oh gotcha gotcha this [ __ ] i got genres
yeah yeah
i saw a little quote i'm the black diplo
oh yeah yeah
i am black diplo once i was like hi
drunk lately it was probably like four
or five more i text i'm like hey bro i'm
about to be the black diplo i'm running
with it and he was like cool
all right good job buddy
yeah man now cause like
i don't know i just feel like i can make
music with anybody bro and i hate when
people put me in the box they should be
lame as hell bro like well the first
song he put out bro
i remember it sounded like 8-bit
[ __ ] was kind of hard though and then
what you came back with was
the you had a foundation just molded
that [ __ ] and that's like i said that's
when i realized like oh producers do
this
the crazy thing on instagram like i hit
up a fire artist like they might do like
some like random like minimal like
alternative music or something of course
they see my page they're like oh he's
just like one of those rap dudes they
don't even know like i probably the
people who usually judge me
on music
haven't even worked with the artists i
work with like bro
so crazy bruh work with
everybody from
from the lead singer coldplay we making
beats and [ __ ] to
who who else bro like so many people
there's a there's a hidden jay balvin
versus out too like bro we i made this
fire song called love and hennessy when
my homie a child but it was about no i
know what you're talking about
right bro jay baldwin had got a verse
for that song bro but he's sponsored by
a different alcohol company
oh damn a lot shot man
but i got a j bible verse i did as hard
as [ __ ] but i'm like oh [ __ ] man all
right i'll do me like that well yeah
it's all good
it sounds hard though it's all the time
now
let's make it the middle of the light
song
all right we're gonna figure that out
i'm glad see i'm glad you said that yeah
there we go but yeah
everybody bro all kind of artists and
producers from every range bruh so like
stop judging me put me in a box really i
don't even know man
so what who who would it be like if you
could work with anybody across any shop
oh like some goal artists
musicians in general
i want to work with shade damn all right
cool
i want to work with um
i want to work with a lot of the
i want to work with you remember those
uh
the
the videos they used to come on vh1 like
those all those rock songs before you go
to school
i'm gonna work with all them like
now like
[Music]
like all them now like creep bro bro
i'll get him to do an outro that
shouldn't be hard
[Laughter]
bruh
i'm trying to do that actively soon
creed around my house out of out of just
fun
so that would be [ __ ] awesome all the
oh man all the early 90s [ __ ] do you
remember man mtv sugar
mark mcgrath that [ __ ] on tv
yeah he's crushing it he's still around
man i feel like he still looks the same
he yeah i could be [ __ ] wrong but
just in my mind he would the [ __ ]
carson daley yet that's a great question
yeah
where's carson daley for real
you want you want one of these joints or
you get another blunt oh yeah let me get
one let me get the blunt bro
yeah and i just wanted to say how cool i
think it is as an artist i've
i've come up i've been a studio rat
since i was a small child
the situation that you facilitated now
with like oh my putting him in position
to like
just have access and to be able to get
in there and just get creative is like
something that all people that want to
do music dream to do
and then that just trickles down
and that's like
as an artist that's just like a major
way of giving back to just like
where you came from to open up your door
to people like that
you never see that like i always like i
always try to open my space to like
other creative people like other
creative people and people who do like
who are like-minded i don't even have to
be
music just
creative [ __ ]
from any kind of art just well just put
all those people in the same room give
them access because i know for me i just
need i just had to get in the studio
like
i didn't know how to win but i just had
to getting one yeah and so yeah like
what you said earlier
be creative as long as you're around if
you're gonna sit here do something
no as long as you're being productive i
think so too but then again i don't know
you guys know all the music [ __ ] i was
in the studio with you guys it's like
one of the other few times a couple
other times that was it
so it's a whole different world like i
told you when i left we're sitting there
i'm rolling a joint
i look up and you're just doing this
hello and it sounds normal on the other
end like what the [ __ ] this was two
steps away from me i couldn't hear
anything you were saying and i can hear
your music coming through it [ __ ]
blew my mind and that dude rolling
around on the chair with 900 buttons in
front of him and that girl was singing a
[ __ ] verse and omar's ass kept
talking and [ __ ] the whole thing up
like dude that shit's crazy
it's great like how like oh you're a
musician you can do this while you're
just texting oh you ready you ready all
right let's go like what the [ __ ] it's
so second i gotta be thinking about it i
can sit down and just like hey what's up
one time i smoked math by accident
that's my [ __ ] like i can tell you a
story in five seconds how a guitar
player plays a guitar that's my happy
story yes i'm just telling them to tell
your story man
so i i like i just it's different for me
and we've been on a streak like last
week we had a gb he's a rapper out of
merced i'm from merced like up in the
[ __ ] ghetto of
california
and
our thing is marty marty moot do you
probably even know marty's story marty
why did you can you give him a little
background on your music [ __ ] because i
butchered it
man i lived the plot to eight mile
basically and i got a licensing deal
with dj skee that led me to move out
here about 10 years ago and then
i just put my all into like my drastic
graphics business and podcasting comedy
started the podcast now i'm circling
back to music now we got a fan base to
kind of slam dunk at lp on them one time
so that was the tracks that i've been
coming in and recording with all my own
[ __ ] so that's what we've been working
on a little three-four track project i
circled back to all my producers in
buffalo and [ __ ]
it's been pretty cool yes sir yeah but
yeah so that's why
does music you do music you do music
it's just it's just different
me as an outsider like a spectator and
i'm saying i love the [ __ ] to see it be
made and to see you guys effortlessly do
this [ __ ] it blows my mind we were
smoking a joint two seconds later i look
up i'm like oh [ __ ] marty's ready rapper
that was the most viewed picture on my
instagram all the time or smoking weed
you're rapping you're looking like a
[ __ ] record exactly
it was just hot yeah like yeah that was
that was an iconic picture but that felt
great man to get in there and just have
those vibes and like omar was telling me
this story that was nipsey's old studio
he's my all-time favorite rapper so like
to go in there and just i knew as soon
as he said that i'm like i know this is
right because i was still not even
knowing if i wanted to do it i just
wanted to do it for the fans
you know because i don't wait and just
because i just to do it because i know
that it's the right thing to do
but
that's what let me know and then we just
came in the vibes were just there like
the last track we did we did in like 40
minutes that one's hardest yeah we may
or may not be getting the mixed down
version of that back tonight it might be
there
yeah but anyway yeah thank you for that
though because that [ __ ] like trickled
down to me and now it's like
you know who knows who knows man but
put me back in touch with myself doing
music again oh yeah getting back into
the process i've been so deep into all
this other like kind of like art you
know like digital media i call it but oh
and one other thing uh there you go
here you're full cell grab oh yeah
yeah you didn't mention that i went
there for a year oh yeah i did that [ __ ]
was so fast bro
that [ __ ] was fast as [ __ ] yeah i lived
in florida for a year brush it was she
was kind of weird because that's the
thing about full sail is that it's
accelerated right so it's not like a
regular college yeah bruh you get a
one class per month and it's 12 months
yup i'm like like crack school where
it's like you're in there at 2 a.m and
[ __ ] right oh yeah you might have a
class at 2 a.m what the [ __ ] like two to
six or two to seven or two to five what
degree
engineering or engineering audio
engineering oh this is all for arts like
yours was graphics i did it online um
for graphic design
but it was like it was 32 months
straight no breaks you get the degree
faster but there's no breaks we did it
online yeah all right 32 miles [ __ ] 32
months every month's a different class
how long do you do the club what's its
class what's full sale what the [ __ ] so
i know you said it before it's just a
college like a trade school for
entertainment careers and we got like
studios and [ __ ] that's what i wanted
yeah so a lot of people like
every year they'll be like this is our
people that graduate from full sell that
made the latest marvel movies in pixar
and that produced the biggest
grammy-nominated awards you know what i
mean like every year there's the whole
class of people like that's that's
[ __ ] tight yeah like some x-men [ __ ]
yeah like even in like entertainment
like law and stuff like that i think
but it's cool like they
i'm still a part of that community yeah
like very much they they put out an
article and stuff like they've showed me
a lot of support well i did go like no
wait i went back in like 2014
15 i don't even know but yeah i went
back when i did go back one time we had
a show in orlando
and i definitely went and you went back
to the campus do you feel like you
needed like looking back on it now how
impactful was college in your and what
you do
now i don't want to make the schools
sound bad just honestly
the first stick you just said [ __ ]
scream
he didn't want to sound like a dick
see yeah see because it's like
i'm a twin like i said i'm a twin right
my sister made straight a's
yeah i told y'all what my record was
i'm like
and i gotta do something bruh
so i'm like let me go to school for
music
yeah give me shaw yeah let me let me let
me try that so i did so i it it taught
me it did teach me
it did
but with everything especially with
music and entertainment
the real learning is when you touch that
[ __ ] when you go out like i was saying
like when i went to that yeah and they
let me touch it like there's people
behind me and i'm like making a beat or
doing something that's when it start but
they they definitely no they introduced
me to the mac uh they introduced me to
apple that's what okay
they shipped me that [ __ ] macbook
that changed my life that's what it was
that's what it was yeah
yeah okay i would have never got that a
macbook bruh
they fronted you the macbook yeah they
front you the macbook it's real it's
real dope [ __ ] like
they front you the macbook like
say no more back in [ __ ] 2000 yeah
that's what it is seven or whatever that
was a complete game changer for sure oh
my god i just remembered that so that's
what shout out to shout out to full self
shout out to full set for real sorry to
[ __ ] on you guys but shout out to
fulsome
from me like [ __ ] school i [ __ ] hate
school is there there's probably i would
imagine is there anybody on youtube that
you follow that might be like really
good at like teaching people how to get
into production and stuff
i'm sure that you probably don't sit
around watching this type of [ __ ] but
i'm not i i watch
i like watching my favorite producers
just in the studio they don't even got
to show me their tricks like i love
those old videos they're watching back
in the day i'm watching like neptune's
or pharrell in the studio or like even
zays over there
i just like watching my favorite artists
and producers in the studio so i'm like
all right
that's cool i kind of i can kind of see
and hear what's going on but um
on like there's a couple of dudes i
think this dude named heimbach or some
[ __ ] on youtube
he'll kind of show you [ __ ] but it's
really more intro to like equipment yeah
i don't know mm-hmm yeah i told you i'm
like it hit me bro i just like this yeah
like
[ __ ] is the is the business side does
that like frustrate you at all or do you
like have a good system for it oh yeah
that [ __ ] sucks like but
what you just said at this point i got a
good system going and [ __ ] it's the
early stuff that's crazy separate
yourself from it it's nice way early
bruh you really got to pay attention to
being on your [ __ ] like thank god i was
blessed my early my homies who helped me
out early tune day and shine they run a
big ass company ovr right now they found
me a good lawyer i was just about i was
gonna sign some [ __ ] like
when i first made my first time making
rain i was
three people tried to sign me one person
tried to sell me for like two bands
yeah and it would have been like all my
[ __ ] like probes and everything like two
bands one person i almost signed for
like five bands one time they almost had
me because i was broke bro i was like
some wayne's world [ __ ] here's five
thousand dollars yeah
like i almost took it and not even
knowing the importance of everything but
i didn't take it though thank god and i
ended up finding like a good lawyer and
like we waited and like we figured [ __ ]
out but
i know a lot of people that probably
didn't have that
perk that i had like so
all the early producers and artists just
i feel like the blueprints are out now
like you can go on youtube and figure
this [ __ ] out like
look at all this watch all the scary
videos like i feel like all my life i
watch behind the music and driven and
all those shows that used to come on
yeah and like what else but
it's a he true hollywood stories all
them [ __ ] so i'm like don't be that guy
exactly where the [ __ ] up i just always
remembered that like yeah don't be that
like i'm seeing this for a reason just
just to try not to make like the tlc one
like they're actually
broke yeah they have been ripped off in
a horrible area look like yeah so that
always stuck with me so i'm like yeah
and like really i don't even
i don't know the music business is the
music business but make sure you want
your [ __ ] though
yeah
your [ __ ] though always assume
everybody's trying to get better get
over on you and you're going to blow
your first check whether you like it or
not
just make sure you blow it on the right
[ __ ] stuff that you could maybe sell
back if you go [ __ ] up like my first
first check i blew like
200 000 but i bought all music equipment
though oh that's good that's what i'm
saying i had to i bought a studio
and
i bought i had yeah i had all the
equipment i wanted i went about spit
everything though like
every like literally everything like
[ __ ]
but that was your investment yeah yeah
so yeah so is that the same [ __ ] you
work with now
some of it a lot like a lot of it i like
leveled up for him you know i mean i
ended up giving it to another studio i
gave it to charlie actually in his time
oh no [ __ ]
yeah that's a go that's a full circle
right there
i love that so speaking of
the early the early days i looked up
some of your [ __ ] because obviously when
we do
episodes of people i actually have met
and or know
it's a little different but hey man
what was your dad like it's different
and i'm also not going to ask that when
we're smoking weed like hey man
what's your family like that's the most
awkward conversation i ever heard right
so this [ __ ] is what i want to ask i
looked up a little bit of stuff don't
want to read into too much because i
want to hear from you your first big
tour that you went on i read it said
iggy azalea
yeah i guess it was not cause i i used
to do her like early music too like
slick founder like
that [ __ ] was like an accident i was
working with this producer he had just
worked made like a beyonce song or some
[ __ ] so he was like popping but like he
used to let me come to his studio and
[ __ ]
so i just used to be in there watching
and [ __ ]
sometimes they let me click a button and
[ __ ] but
this artist come through from she at
before then i don't know she i don't
know where she came from like texas or
something but like yeah she came and
everything we kicked it
like we were just kicking in the studio
i was helping her make music and
everything and then i linked her with
this other chick because like she needed
like
she needed like she needed like some a
country girl to be around her like who
knows [ __ ] like
who just know the world you know i mean
she was like from australia and [ __ ] i
linked them she kind of schooled their
own [ __ ] this guy you know what i mean
showed her around
they started making random youtube
videos
we started making more and more music we
split from the other producer i was
working with some [ __ ] happened
he wasn't paying me or some [ __ ] some
crazy [ __ ] happened
my headphones went off anyway
we uh
do they unplug
good all right so yeah yeah we we split
apart from the that random producer guy
oh yeah i remember her mom was sending
money from australia or something to pay
me and the guy was keeping it
like yeah it was crazy
so i was like yo man forget that dude
mind you i'm still broke you ain't got
none
but random we still recording this like
trap like charlie and travis porter
turned a old chocolate factory
it's funny his name is chuck charlie
don't lie you ask them you go see this
[ __ ]
it was in like it was in
like right outside of downtown atlanta
like 10 minutes out of atlanta like
it was this random small little house
like a little chocolate factory house
thing and we made a studio in there
and like
that i brought iggy through one time
they like they even know who she was
that time and at that daytime they were
lit especially in atlanta like hey i
think not hey ladies making rain was
like still up or something like that we
used to record this little chocolate
house bro
even down to one time we in there
recording a lady comes in like can i buy
some chocolate get the [ __ ] she tried
like thinking you old lady thinking to
steal the shot shut down the german
chocolate factories nah we ain't here
smoking gag
making beats and [ __ ] you talk about
ladies that's a [ __ ] culture shot for
that lady right there so yeah
fast forward she ended up moving to l.a
that [ __ ] song come out
that [ __ ] go up like she was working
with a couple other producers too and um
that [ __ ] went up bro and i was just
around and she needed like somebody to
play the music
yeah
so you went on tour
was that like the first one like
i guess yeah first time out the country
and [ __ ] i went to like oh [ __ ] yeah i
went all through i i i know of this this
this girl i don't know any songs i'm not
going to be this is not but it's not
this was completely random this dot like
this is another thing i try to tell my
homies and like
who make music and younger dudes bruh
you never know what's going to put you
on
the [ __ ] you thinking is the complete
opposite is what's going to put you on
like 100
in my dreams that i used to have i
thought like pharrell was going to call
me one day or timbaland and be like it's
time young man
it's time to pass the torch
fly to miami it's time we about to do
this [ __ ] i didn't think it was going to
be like and like i'm happy it's like
this yeah anything was going to be
three with my random homies from the
east side of atlanta who we were gonna
make platinum songs with like and [ __ ]
like i
never would have thought that like
i'm like i'm saying i'm glad it happened
down to her like
i was just trying to figure out how to
work at this studio
i was working for them i wasn't getting
money that i was supposed to get because
her mom was sending it she didn't even
know me so then we were like let's just
go somewhere else and then [ __ ] just
happened fast like it wasn't even like
trying like i can't even just meant to
be at [ __ ] happening like bro like you
never know what person is going to help
you
like you never [ __ ] know you never
[ __ ] know
and yeah it's just i just like rapper oh
where australia yeah white chicken like
huh
what the [ __ ] i have to blow up for real
sick
no i get it no write it all down on
paper like you're [ __ ] lying to me
that no that's what i'm saying if you
someone was telling me everyone like huh
like where are you talking about dog
shut up dog timberland gonna call me
tomorrow dog [ __ ] what are you talking
about
that's oh yeah the complete opposite of
what you were expecting basically that's
why john said like what you think like i
was in there like yeah this
like this is
not even doubting her talking like i
just
i was just there just helping out trying
to be in the studio with random [ __ ]
exactly trying to be there
we preached out on the show all the time
like don't worry about like how just
know like where you want to be and just
leave
room for whatever is going to happen
just do positive things as much as you
possibly possibly can just do
do the work do the work do the work and
like you said earlier money doesn't
can't beat your morals
like earlier you said that's your one of
your regrets i wish i wouldn't take that
[ __ ]
because you could have had a different
song so i i see where you're saying
especially looking back now like you
could have signed a horrible deal
all these he could have smoked that meth
instead oh yeah i could have smoked
there's a lot of different things that
could have happened
so hold on real quick
first time out the country you're on
tour how was that do you have any
anything you take away from that any
experience
that you could think like hey man the
first time i went out the country i
[ __ ] fought a guy
he was eight feet tall i don't know
there's always something bro
this little shits and
throws up at danny duncan doors
he hates you right now he hates me so
bad
first time in london
no that might even say
long story short
somebody tried to drug it tried to drug
iggy but she don't drink i drunk the
butt i drink the box
i got drugs i was in the next club like
hit the ground and then
i remember my friend picking me up and
putting me in a taxi with these random
british [ __ ] and that was it the
hospital
nah
oh [ __ ] he just took you home in the
internet they just took me somewhere i
don't know where i was at i still don't
know i didn't have money or nothing i
was broke into town two years it was
crazy he just shipped you off it's a
condom yeah but luckily i'm a big black
dude i can find my way back
somehow
i got my way back there's not a lot of
the guys that look like me here just
spawned it
yeah
completely passed out though yeah that's
so dangerous i just put me in a taxi
with three [ __ ]
i woke up did she realize that you took
her intended [ __ ] room no i'm
probably later but yeah
i saved your life yeah
you're out here being the body garden
show i was a bodyguard bro unknowingly
the drug tester i [ __ ] with that
remember that job bro i know 62 people
just volunteered right now in the chat
they must have got the whole bottle i
can't forget it was a whole bottle of
sorak bro
you drank the whole [ __ ] nobody else
drink out of it i mean not because
she don't drink
at all so um
like we don't like i'm i'm pretty
private too if you're not with me with
me i don't really need you around me so
we probably it was probably like bottles
and bottles and bottles and bottles like
damn yeah and i just happened to pick
the one with the woop in it
yeah
so that's a good story i guess it's not
fine
guys but
that's [ __ ] up could have woke up in
hostile or some [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh yeah
that would have been that's that's how
he scares the [ __ ] out of me yeah
we've talked about it before but that
[ __ ] happened to me too
opposite i was there i won't say where i
was at a strip club the lady seemed so
nice i ordered a [ __ ] drink it was
for my [ __ ] girl
[ __ ] they tried to roofie me
i think the towels by myself oh
[ __ ] dude we're just sitting there 20
minutes later she's like [ __ ] almost
throwing up past now like what the [ __ ]
we didn't drink
you can't drink it this place is a
[ __ ] lemonade so yeah it almost
happened to me too
despite the non that's brutal that's
[ __ ] up it was a lemonade man hey man
stop ooping the drinks y'all this is
crazy stop man if i ever feel dizzy in a
nightclub i'm running straight out into
the street and screaming
i don't give a [ __ ] bro stop woo
jumped out the window um all right so uh
one one thing uh omar asked me to ask
you
he said there's a story involving you
post malone wiz khalifa that i should
ask about
funny ass story all right
did you you we've clarified that he's
credited for discovering oh that was my
next thing all right you know let's go
into that first
go for it marty
first of all i don't know anything about
that except that
so i
i just remember omar telling like yeah i
posted one when i walked into that
studio like it's a big record
all right cool so that's what that
that's what i was talking about and then
he told me about post because i germ
jill is a per don't know if you remember
jeremy that's my boy yo you know jeremy
hey nice i haven't seen you in a minute
[ __ ] hey man shout out johnny
german's around earl out of early time
everything he put me on
it was like three weeks old and he's
like check this out it's called white
irish and i'm like this shit's hard
let's watch him blow the [ __ ] up in like
two months he's gonna be the biggest
artist that's what he told me i was at
his uh apartment right there off the
five or off the 110 right there when he
was all with pink diamond still that's
how long ago this was
and that's the first time i ever heard
of him i heard of mcconan there
and then i heard of
uh
i can't remember else it was a future
first time ever heard future was with
jeremy
so how did you discover this
long-haired ass kid
so i pulled up to a stevie b studio
my 18th birthday that's my concert i
went to stevie b i pulled up the stevie
what the [ __ ] i pulled up the stevie b
studio bro
i'm saying
throwback random i didn't even know it
was stevie b studio oh i thought you
meant let me know i called stevie
he was there though
he was there he was there
but so i played
steve b studio i meet him like all right
cause i knew cause i knew his songs and
everything like it's hard because like
from here for my parents and [ __ ] ain't
that them [ __ ] was gone
i'm just jamming really still jamming
like still just the hardest sample all
the time yeah
so anyway
that's stevie b studio cooling
my partner jb there he was like hey man
uh am i playing a rap or whatever i'm
like alright it's gonna come through
so he pull up
never forget he had like the random
yellow yankee jersey i'm like man that's
your heart a random cool i mean like he
was like rapping like but he was rapping
hard though like [ __ ]
it was just fire [ __ ] he was just saying
real like drippy [ __ ] like real fire
[ __ ]
i'm like all right so yeah we got to
start cooking or whatever
fast forward we start cooking cooking
cooking he was like you should move into
the crib in l.a
because he was like staying with his
friend or whatever
shout out down to he's staying with his
friend he was like we could just make my
bedroom
studio
bro really we really made it a studio
bro was in the closet sleeping in the
closet bro like
dead ass it was great it was crazy still
smoking 100 cigarettes don't know how he
got him but he was still smoking
he was still smoking 100 cigarettes
yeah we just started cooking in there we
started meeting so many like so many
people his manager now dre
he started pulling up like everything
just started like
just forming like it was it was it was
amazing i didn't even fully know what
was happening but i
but i could feel it or whatever
long story short we make white iverson
boom that's like a year that's about a
year later a little less than that maybe
right after that wiz khalifa tells us to
come to his house
mind you
post most 100 cigarettes i smoke 100
blunts
wherever we go we're like the tag team
like the dudley bros when it comes to
smoking
bro
the dudley bros are smoking bruh
so we had wiz khalifa house he ain't
even there yet i feel like he's not even
there his engineer let us in
we like listening to beats or something
listening to the beast i don't know if i
was playing beats we cooling
whiz comes
like
she's gonna thrown off a little bit
that's everybody up
he's cooling for like
a minute
then just leaves like
we didn't even know he left bro he just
left like we still there looking for
beats like out two hours later
brother left he couldn't handle the
smoke bro is you're smoking inside this
house i mean in the studio cigarettes
and uh
that's something that engineer though
right like you should have said like man
hey what's going to come in here
hey man i feel strictly smoking joints
too you can't you can't you can't you
can you can't tell that you can't you
can't tell uh post not smoking sick man
okay
that's crazy smoking cigs inside
1982
and i was smoking big bloods dude
[Music]
he never came back
i've never seen him again
i think oh in general i think i saw him
again for the first time at post
listening to for his new album like a
couple months ago yeah i never saw him
again since then
he hates you guys like those will stink
bro don't bring a movie
i've never seen her fall smoking a
cigarette in a [ __ ] studio before
that [ __ ]
that shit's girl right that's a break
sinatra [ __ ] exactly there is though
that's what it's pretty far like yeah
i've seen he he damn he'd be damn near
be smoking cigarettes everywhere
[ __ ]
so that's how you discover this kid
right that's a that's a trip what are
the odds you hear that
is he from l.a originally or no no
oh texas okay damn that's a trip man i'd
love to hear that though like
all that [ __ ] sleeping in the closet
just that year that it took he really
dig right he was grinding that [ __ ] out
you really did run that [ __ ] out for
real it was figuring [ __ ] out oh and
then we had like we had some [ __ ]
over and [ __ ] and there's one black girl
braided his hair
and
i thought it was a south by southwest
interview i remember that one it was
real like the very beginning and jeremy
was showing me and i looked him up ready
his hair
and he noticed his power in the hair
he was feeling himself did that art did
that come after the title yeah i'm
saying he made i'm saying he made the
song oh after the braids oh [ __ ] it
iverson brothers oh okay all right i
like it more now damn look at that
haircut super cuts where the [ __ ] you at
man you could be putting on artists out
here
what the [ __ ] you slipping
damn
he made it classic
[ __ ]
you never know like you said you never
know what's gonna [ __ ] do it and that
was your dead ass kick at it like then
how do you like this weed i haven't
tried it yet today it's my first time
trying this week i'm digging it i'm
digging it cool it's a skittle cross
my skittle cross i dig it yeah it's all
right right i used to only smoke og
so this is this is a cool do you
consider yourself a weed snob
yes
but
i've been in positions where i've had to
smoke bad weed before
it was i don't i don't
i don't like it it's things i regret
[Music]
rio de janeiro
you have the worst weed ever no
really you know what that's true brazil
i have a lot of fans send me brick brick
weed pictures
i'm not saying it's all bad smoke it
it's just
i got a
sore throat two hours after smoking it
like
like locked up like
i've had some bamboo that makes my money
but i do love rio shout out to everybody
in brazil i [ __ ] with brazil
but [ __ ] the weed
you know there's eight people going to
comment you didn't just come to the
right spot and they're [ __ ] show me
fire pictures i bet i bet obligato
write it down thank you i think that's
thank
i hope you got him yeah right please
that's just out of japanese
be honest not japanese is uh
damn i forgot but i know i did dave i
did i found some on there never mind no
i know i didn't find a way in
japan no you didn't know i don't smoke
in japan
is fake there's no weed there no no laws
are broken
yo japan's scary don't smoke weed in
japan yeah i'm blocked in russia and we
can't watch any of my [ __ ] in russia
they don't [ __ ] with wheat at all in
russia
they don't [ __ ] be scared i'm scared
in america with me and i'd be scared
[Laughter]
oh man
all right so
whoa oh [ __ ] i had a question i was just
about to ask you i didn't write it down
i won't forget it
so i got it so like what's what's the
next we know you've been out on these
like
studio sessions where you're having
everybody come through is there like a
project that you're working on is there
something like in the next year like
you're talking about stepping up to be
the actual the artist and the producer
that is going to be coming out
yeah um i just actually released a
project called last player alive
last player yeah
the last one alive man
it's christian crazy out here bro y'all
know y'all know what it's like out here
bro you know what it's like from the
victim so i'm just tell i'm just letting
everybody know what it's like to be the
last player alive man it's just chris a
crazy life
you're talking two dudes have been with
their girls for like [ __ ] 30 years
combined here
well thank you
thank you for the info and [ __ ] yeah
nice
it's all there man it's it's all there
where can they find that at
of course youtube
itunes apple music
it is fki first on there yeah fki first
last player alive what is what does fki
first stand for
forever kicking it oh [ __ ] okay love it
i like the title like first time in
london bam that's the album first time
then fill the blank
it's tough the reason my name is first
is because i'm a twin that's one of them
oh
get the [ __ ] out i was born first damn
first [ __ ] grades first
yo i love that dude when did you take
that moniker on early on just rubbing it
in and [ __ ] like yeah well when i was
young my nickname random was troche
troakie
like some matilda [ __ ] a jokey that's
what that's the first second thing i
heard
how did you get the nickname man
wait what happened what happened in
matilda matilda remember the chokey they
[ __ ] put him in the box it was that
nails in it his name was choking no it
was called the choke
the hole with the nails miss trunchbulls
my mind was trophy like how and why
my first now my first name is like uh
troco
oh that's your that's how you say it
oh [ __ ] then you say it all with the
inflection i was spelling it too at the
same time
so uh they say yeah my sister's called
me trochee
i gotta ask
what did your sister go on to do
having all those crazy ass i was
wondering that great oh she snapped she
snapped um
she worked at google for a minute damn
okay so she did some [ __ ] yeah she
snapped
um
did she ever make fun of everybody look
what we're doing but i didn't try hard
in school oh yeah
i would be talking [ __ ]
like how good were all these guys really
break it down
i really just been sliding like
[Laughter]
like cruising this whole time yeah
like
thank god but um but that go back to
being the last player alive if you
listen i can show you how to do that too
i can show you how to slide like
you know what i mean
yeah you know i could show you how to
slide through you know i mean yeah
yeah yeah then she did all that studying
and [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
well she
she cried when she made like she made
like a b or c at uga i think she cried
oh she's one of those kids
i'm a if you give me a 69.9 like my past
celebrations uh
yeah as long as i'm not in trouble at
home yeah this [ __ ] does not matter yeah
but with that for some people and
everybody kids is good yeah not
everybody not everybody some of you
[ __ ]
i feel like at that age even you kind of
just know like i'm not going to have
this isn't going to be my lifestyle i
can kind of tell you already knew when
they were in until ninth grade when they
ran out of school after school the
football team i was like oh yeah that's
it
oh last thing real quick little [ __ ] we
just saw omar showed me you're making
that little beat looking at the coliseum
and now that shit's in coliseums
everywhere
that's some [ __ ] that you could take to
your old man like stage telling stories
like hey that song i [ __ ] did that no
cat that's real manifestation [ __ ] like
right there we were so close to that
[ __ ] that's kind of odd they made a
hotel that close to some
ancient [ __ ] that's like it was like a
career it was like an airbnb type [ __ ]
it wasn't odd though like it was just
directly right
close like close that's where it's
closed oh that's where bruce lee stayed
in [ __ ] chinese can is a chinese
connection where he goes to rome and
he's in the [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] looking it up right after
this
ah what's the [ __ ] movie where is the
chicken with the colors
you wanted to punch them
i know [ __ ]
damn dude sorry i'm just that just
hitting my head right now i'm i'm
[ __ ] high anyway that's cool
every sports game
in america
well i had no idea he showed me oh yeah
i've heard that everywhere it's in every
[ __ ] arena that's the sports song
it's not we're the champions anymore
right back to queen
did you know you were making that for
him in that moment or were you just
making a beat and it ended up just going
afterwards i was just making the beat
right there you're looking at that [ __ ]
i don't know
hey i told you i was just
probably smoking just faded looking at
it i don't know
is that so like what's your normal
workflow like is that are you is this
every day like are you just in the
groove of like i'm in the studio at
night i'm making beats it's just like
almost like a five days a week oh yeah
oh seven no this [ __ ] don't stop
i'm a maniac when it comes to like
the studio and working and [ __ ] it's
kind of like i i feel like it's my like
my african side kind of all like but
like my my spanish friends they'll be
like yeah man i'm working you know this
is how we work like for real like that's
how i feel like whenever i just like i
have to be working like
yeah i just
even when i'm nice have to be around
because like i did something i have
figured out too with this music [ __ ]
if you miss an idea it's gonna go right
down in the street to the next person
what the [ __ ] we've been saying that
[ __ ] like
little waves like
like i even feel like there's producers
and a couple artists i feel like we be
thinking the same [ __ ] like i feel like
we even think like it down to the point
where we
we think we accidentally stole something
from each other but nah we just on that
same wave bro like
and i'm sure it happens to them how it
happens to me like i'll get something
like an idea or some creative idea
whether it's visual or
music
and miss i might miss it i didn't do it
or maybe did it and then put it out but
that person on that same wave called it
and they see their problems it's so
weird how [ __ ] real it just does it's
so rude
how many times you anybody at home every
time you go i just thought of that [ __ ]
somebody beat me to it it's because you
[ __ ] up it didn't capitalize because
that happened so many times and it
happened to
big
fire situations it kind of made me a
maniac where like i'm not leaving
anything i got on my brain is coming out
i ain't missing this [ __ ] right i just i
thought it was weird but no that's just
a great way to put it on it like it's
like a comedian right [ __ ] that's an
interesting thing though because you're
going back to the same blank drawing
board every time you go into like making
a new beat it's like how do you you're
going back to your same toolbox you got
to pull out different sounds
that's that's what you're feeling i
think right
yeah it's all feeling and depending on
who's in the room too that's why it's
good to have five people in the room
creative people in the room
like with good vibes because it could
come from just
one person saying something the crazy
thing is when somebody says something
serious
and i think of a song right when they
say something serious and i'm like oh
that's hard i've done it i've said it
somebody told me some serious [ __ ] like
i'm just i'm making an example like
yo
i'm just making something like yo hold
up
man
my girl's doing this man my mind's
playing tricks on me i'll be like oh my
god mine's playing tricks on me [ __ ]
that is hard
but he's like telling me something about
it
i can do that it's like crazy it's
[ __ ] up though but that's how it is
crazy i'm in that [ __ ] dog brain just
works that way it's always crazy
i feel bad but i write down things my
sometimes it's serious [ __ ] i always i'm
very sorry but i'm gonna write it down
real quick under crazy [ __ ] my friend
said [ __ ] my friend said it's called
friend talk now on my phone i've written
down some very my homie told
mohammed
but there's so many situations you're
like yo that's that's just that's
hysterical
but let me tell you some [ __ ] [ __ ]
though
i know people
this is why it's scary too having a lot
of people in the room i'm saying i like
having a lot of people in the studio
because at the same time how we say
we'll tell somebody there's people who
won't tell anybody
and just steal it like oh
and you say like no i made it up
oh bro that's that must be terrible it
is that's like writing it's like writing
your [ __ ] your brain out and
everyone's just maybe i'm recording this
[ __ ] my phone mm-hmm that's [ __ ] up
that'll make you better as a producer
he's like the whole time listen to his
beats i'm ripping it i've seen
everything yeah yeah
yeah i've caught producer i've also
called producers on my computer
literally
dragging stuff over you know how you can
you know copy things up like they took
it down when everybody left the room i
come back
and they're still transferring the song
i'm like what the [ __ ] like no count i
literally look at dudes i'm just like
disconnected i'm like man just get out
bro like
they're just literally taking stuff like
that's weird as [ __ ] insane bro i don't
know i wouldn't be able to sleep though
like yo you love that song huh i wish i
wrote it i wish i made this [ __ ] if you
only knew bro there's a lot of those
bruh
there's a lot of those bro that's a
[ __ ] bummer to here yeah man
maybe that's why a lot of [ __ ] salt
like that [ __ ] sounds like the other
[ __ ]
but you just can't get jaded though
that's the thing you cannot get jaded
that's like
because i know people who are jaded and
it's just like yeah a lot of lives
because most producers aren't actually
making enough money to survive
right so i've seen like yeah you can't
get jaded though you really just got to
keep believing in your beats and like
the intention like
it's the intentions when you make it
kind of like however i was making it in
front of the [ __ ] coliseum [ __ ] like
that song hey ladies okay now lady when
we made that song we literally said bruh
we have to compete with back that ass up
like oh
no [ __ ] bring it back in they like we
literally said that in the studio he was
like bruh what can we do
to beat back that ass up not saying they
beat it or not but it still plays back
to back with that to it like that's
your intentions when you go in and do
[ __ ] we literally said it like you have
to like you're looking at the classic
yeah like
i like that though this era because i
always say like what's my cult classic
it's got to be at least as good as this
like it's got to make me at least as
hyped as [ __ ] happy gilmore made me
as a kid
like i love that like always the feeling
like i just want people to have that
feeling my thing is like remember when
this football was over and then an hour
later the simpsons came on i'm like oh
[ __ ] like that's how i want people to
feel like every month o'clock yeah
it's a month it's three o'clock our
[ __ ] show's coming on that's and like
you said i want people to have that
feeling of when i first heard [ __ ]
another one bites dust or some [ __ ]
whatever our camera what song you're
talking about but you know what i'm
saying from the queen
there's so much that you could do
with just
i think i've said i think i said it yeah
i was just saying reiterate the same
[ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah um before we get out here man
where can everybody find you where can
everybody listen to stuff where can
everybody follow you and support
whatever you're doing
good gas
good job first
that's where everything is i got all the
good gas for you all the good music all
the collaborations
from jack harlow
to
bees to draco the ruler ralphie that's
all good guys collaborations to find me
i'm a good job first instagram
youtube
we're popping up on the screen yeah like
this is why i got a social media manager
no we'll pop it up we'll find out i just
wanted to ask good job first following
man good job goodgats.com too right
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i was with you until you gave
out your [ __ ] website
oh [ __ ]
all right well cool
oh man thank you for coming out today
hold on wait what's the
it's good guys
because you got stuck
oh i thought the clicks was like saying
yup that's why i was like all right cool
good guy dude
you hit that coke
so it translates
bro [ __ ]
that's a first on the show
i don't know where that from it's all
right
bilingual i didn't even know it didn't
even know it
could be like that channeling omar i saw
you falling asleep a minute ago that
fool smoked one blunt
he's got he's got no he's got no
tolerance left
he wakes up where are those shark things
he'll be eating bro oh you want some
sharks
i always see him oh martin like stealing
you can touch him
you [ __ ] can you get the sharks
this bull steals all my [ __ ] animals
bro easily easy to develop a pretty
serious yeah
oh you're kidding me hold up
hold up
i'm not a trip
yeah that's just a big empty liquor
store
i'm shoving 10 sharks
there was 30 in there a minute ago i
guess
all right here we go hold on
sorry youtube
sorry youtube
youtube
hey
here you go
remember uh slush puppies from the
liquor store
the little dog with the icees remember
that [ __ ] from the liquor store that's
what the [ __ ] it tastes like
try one
oh i thought you were giving me this i'm
like oh [ __ ] no it's yours i'm saying he
wouldn't eat one right now
i got a hell of a [ __ ]
i wouldn't do that to you
i won't show this because this is coming
out soon so i'll just show the back of
it
same same flavor oh okay did that [ __ ]
taste like a slush puppy
is that the
the new line
well nevermind those are way stronger so
you're good
i'm just letting you know
just in case it's in case
it might be high they're gonna get you
[ __ ] up i will say that
should be all right
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] just got powerful i just
smashed all my [ __ ] pack
sorry all right
got some munchies the shit's [ __ ] bro
you know what the weirdest thing of all
time is my little faces on the back and
it trips me the [ __ ] out
it trips me out people will be sending
me this [ __ ] all over the states like yo
i'm getting high
legally
yeah we can ship this [ __ ] any state
that's what makes it so dope
and if i'm white out look at this
they taste good too so it's like they
don't taste like anything but candy huh
i'd be careful is that your number two
no i'm saying one okay all right say b
little cautious look at this fool i
killed the tail
i killed the tail
smoking that pan
brand new pan we're doing a bunch of
[ __ ] right now let's go when are we
doing the smoke off oh this is a real
question before we started this is the
third time he had brought this up so
he's serious
first wants to have a smoke off with me
but the last time i what the [ __ ]
wait what oh i know what happened i know
what happened that happens to me
sometimes i know what happened
if you're a real smoker you know
sometimes i think smoke is a person
coming around the corner the sound board
oh wait wait he just scared the phone
[ __ ] out of me so i just told myself
about smoke
let me tell you some [ __ ] about a person
let me put this back on let me tell you
some funny ass [ __ ]
to all my people with dreads and who
smoke weed and [ __ ] oh the hair
oh carter
check this out
so look
at me sorry about that i've been high as
hell right and been smoking he's happy i
don't know the same time
like
if i'm moving too quick
like
my peripheral disc looks especially like
if it's dark and it's one lit little way
it's just a shadow sometimes it looks
literally like somebody ran past or uh
and sometimes i might think my hair is
tied up behind my head too like it's cr
like so i'll be like what the [ __ ]
i do a lot of these yeah a lot of a lot
of a lot of those yeah bro what happened
to the sound he put some scariest sound
on me he said you challenged you said i
challenged you to the thing and i was
just
[Music]
i scared the [ __ ] out of me because i
was in conversation bro i didn't think a
sound was going to scare the [ __ ] out of
it
that's from justice that justice song
bro
that's the gesture you know stress
oh [ __ ] i have no idea i believe you you
know i believe stock suspense
my brain is like a jukebox [ __ ] crazy
you just went you just went through a
database about yeah two trillion songs
hold up look hold up hold up if it is
bruh
no i don't know what y'all owe me
hold on
no no no look it was the it was saying
bro
[Music]
oh no it ain't
close close that's hard though close
it's the sound with the squirrel
remember that meme from my bean bombs
world
with the squirrel that looked over at
the camera that's the scent that's the
sound
that's hard scared the [ __ ] out of me i
was in mid conversation i scare you
though because i [ __ ] heard like
it sounded like someone was creeping i
don't know it scared the [ __ ] out of me
i know you i've scared the [ __ ] out of
him with all kinds of [ __ ] gunshots are
different
oh [ __ ] is that a fart noise that's the
fail horn
oh
my son was just doing
[Music]
now that this guys can hear what's
happening right now anyway sorry this
guy did scare the [ __ ] out of me so
i don't even know what i was talking
about but scared the [ __ ] out of me oh
oh people gotta put one side gun back on
here yeah i know i was looking for it
earlier hey yo yo my hair scares the
[ __ ] out of me too in the night
especially in my room with no one's but
i know no one's next to me wait what
does it do because my hair's long as
[ __ ] when it's not done
oh yeah when i was smoking i do
the same [ __ ] happen i do like oh [ __ ]
you i do a lot of this [ __ ] in my house
what are you talking about
i'm sorry we gotta yes you're like
the smoker hell no you don't i love
horror movies that's what you need them
bro that's why i'm always on my toes too
because i've been watching my toes i've
been watching horror movies since i was
like five so i don't like my dad made me
watch chucky as a kid i love turkey it
scared the [ __ ] out of me as a kid my
sister had porcelain dolls i slept in
the same room
every [ __ ] night was a horror movie
for me bro
speaking of child's play that movie and
the dog and the [ __ ] dog my old my
older sister had one and she always had
one since she was like because she was
older so it was older it was an older
dog and it was like it was like
life-size
me and my twin sister like we we saw
chuckie like [ __ ] me up i said about a
month after we was like hey yo we got to
get ready bro like
we took it and literally threw it in the
woods like did they get it back though
did it come back
i don't know i never thought i would
have [ __ ] oh let me tell you about
that i always thought one day i was
gonna go in the basement if i'm like
this [ __ ] is down here bro it's a wrap
yeah
it's a wrap cause she had hella
porcelain dolls i would put stuff on
them so if they moved i would know that
you
and goosebumps came out 911 dummy and
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] all that those
toys [ __ ] [ __ ] remember with me to
choose your own adventure
are you talking about goosebumps in the
book yeah man you might
did you ever go to a page ahead and
check to see if you was going to go out
first unlocked
i didn't want to cheat because i knew if
i cheated it's like skipping ahead of
the movie and i don't want to [ __ ] it up
i mean this girl was just talking about
that
i [ __ ] do something i was like
you guilty she was guilty
she was guilty i didn't like one time
what you know about that turn to page
67.
turn the page one on two you're a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no why didn't i do that though do you
remember people doing that [ __ ] no i
would follow it all the end you're whack
40 pages
so if i could go back in time i want to
go back in time just to do that bro oh
yeah i'm just playing hard and that's
not what i want to do if i went back in
time i don't know i definitely would win
more [ __ ]
marble poison games those [ __ ] some
of those kids man when i was a kid i
wasn't good at that
no that's what i'm saying they thought
they were
all the my whole group remember i told
you yeah a whole group of like these
group of asian kids i used to play
marbles with every day but i'd steal
these so i cracked their [ __ ] but if not
they would win
poisons on two shots [ __ ] you that's
like a par [ __ ] two
wait what happened right now
you remember marbles the poison you dig
a hole in the ground if you make it in
there you you get the marble that's next
to you you thought you were doing the
finger pops no but i'm talking about the
marble
oh nah i thought you were talking about
the game where
either you break a pencil or you hit the
other kid's hand until until you they
give up
what game is this what'd you guys with
the quarterback
yeah we do like when bloody knuckles i
put the knuckles yeah that's what i'm
saying we think about i never even seen
that like yeah keep hitting the your
other person's finger until they can't
do it anymore never saw that yeah
or you break a pencil oh hell no i never
played that you ever that was the
dumbest game the abc game with the
eraser my town's dumb you take the
eraser off a pencil
and try to do as many abcs as you can
and the kid that gone the longest wins
there's fools bleeding like that's the
dumbest game i ever saw [ __ ] ghettos
whack my game that was crazy i know but
i didn't play it
i would never play like we just erased
our flesh off the abc game it was the
dumbest [ __ ] that's what it was called
or the you miss a free throw everybody
beat your [ __ ] ass until you don't
push the pole did you ever play that
that sucked oh that [ __ ] sucks when you
play football in the street um
inside this grass sideline bus
you can hit him under the gap yeah we do
sideline bus bro so we'll be on concrete
but the side of the sides will be yards
so it's like if you catch that [ __ ] on
you on and you're on the side it's your
ass blitz and blitz was out the game
blitz was out so that's where we got it
from so
sideline bus if you was on the sideline
that's your ass i always try to stay in
the middle trying to be ready
everybody looked up to randy moss how
old are you uh 31 oh so we're the same
same [ __ ] randy moss was the [ __ ] man
and when he fake mooned everybody and
did oh man he was the [ __ ] man with
that sharp being or no but that was true
owens with the shark behind or was it
randy monster the sharpie
i mean he signed the when he touched her
at his ankle right it was toronto
he was a [ __ ] monster for a while
yeah so i'm assuming we got him for a
year he's like 50. should i have to ask
just falcons buffalo
i'm from [ __ ] california i'm a
packers fan so i had to ask man i miss
julio but julio jones mm-hmm
falcons had it for a while man falcons
were good for like matt ryan was like a
little peyton manning for a few years
then he just started falling the [ __ ]
off
sorry ryan i know you're a fan you just
called him rhett ryan did i say matt
ryan
[Music]
should get my ass
this tall white man oh it's [ __ ] man
right you gotta beat my [ __ ] ass you
never know man cause i'm gonna meet
brett favre one day yeah still it might
be with matt ryan it might not be good
what does matt ryan sound like
you don't even know
like like a lawyer
paralegal problem here to whoop your ass
and throw pick
three times in a row
all right so
all right thank you thank you for being
here bro we're about to get on some
garage face time conversation [ __ ] no i
appreciate it man everybody it's fki
first good job first and good guess
dot co
oh it's though now damn
the goodgas.com remixed it up mid
[ __ ] podcast
all right damn i got link in description
goo
all right guys thank you so much
appreciate y'all it's from the candy man
it's all over me thank you for being
here thank you for smoking it up so the
smoke off coming soon
all right i say we start off with half
zip joints
do one of those and if you're down for
the if you don't want to do the hash
we're gonna think of some creative [ __ ]
for this weed
because enough we we're gonna go through
ounces all right you know so we got to
make it fun
coming soon all right we got to get
those rules right we're going to yeah we
have to get it because i can't smoke it
back
i can't smoke papers like that right
then that's fine we'll trade you that's
the one
oh we just keep going bad no no i can't
no i'm saying we tr like that's the
trade-off like you can smoke your your
backwards i'll smoke my joints because
you can't we can't i can't really
come on bro
that's tobacco smoke
what about what about hemp hemp water
and blunts
yeah i've seen them banana papers banana
leaf papers oh yeah yeah uh palm leaves
too yeah if somebody can pre-order
pre-roll them or something
there's a box right there i got a bunch
of them oh let's go
all right all right smoke off smoke off
this is aggressive
i've never had somebody come so [ __ ]
from my neck before let me tell you two
years running now oh and let me tell you
bro i've been getting the word around
town work around town is
i'm up there
smoking
snoop dogg mike
i'm just telling you all right other
people telling like hey yo man be no
people i know who smokes like daddy
snoop dogg mike dean i'm like okay it's
a good category so what's up i'm oh
i'm ready there's a category of ex mess
dealers that i know can smoke a lot
go smoke i'm ready i'm ready for it guys
coming very soon we'll come to the
channel we'll do some [ __ ] smoke off
coming soon i like to sign out the
richard nixon sign out oh no don't tell
me richard nixon
i didn't do it though
he went a little higher
[Music]
thank you for being here man thank you
for smoking it up marty this it was a
magazine oh yeah
across the table appreciate it that's a
just
i can't play air hockey with this
[ __ ] ever from
russia minus that chucky cheese just
dropping them in and [ __ ] i'll go crazy
on them it's hard for me to do push-ups
too i'm like kd bruh it's like my arm's
long i got i feel like you're taking
long hard
[Laughter]
it's so far i'd be like
pros and cons to being tall i think you
got it though
you win bro i think
i can see [ __ ]
i can't do push-ups well though like
i'll say [ __ ] i can see over
[ __ ]
y'all thank you thank you for being here
party thank you thank you jesus christ
all right thank you so much man this has
been a another episode of the dope usual
podcast i'm thomas daviola have a dope
ass day ah that that's [ __ ]
ridiculous bro i know i know for sure
after some edibles we would be here for
three hours i already feel the whole
section
before like i'm saying we would have
been here forever man
i know it would have kept going
right raj has been telling me about
these yeah he's been [ __ ] fevering
he's been stealing all my [ __ ] look at
him rubbing his hands like a like a guy
that's going to get over him
oh yeah it is the birdman
yes
yes get out of here try these eat these
so we're all right i don't i can't say
it online we're gonna be the first
people in the [ __ ] history we're
about
[Music]